We have seen that the opposite angles of a
cyclic quadrilateral add up to
180° A quadrilateral is cyclic when a
circle passes through all its four vertices of course it is an
important property but we need to prove this result We are given
that a
quadrilateral is a CD  Cyclic and we have to
prove that its opposite angles add
up to
180° This means angle a + angle c equals
180° and angle b + angle d equals
180° The figure we have is absolutely blank nothing given to us about
the sides and  The
Angles The Only Thing We Do Know Is That All The
Four Vertices a b s and d lie on the
circle since the figure tells us nothing Let's try and
analyze what we have to prove
First we have to prove that the sum of the
angles is
180  ° Looking at this
180° we would probably have to form a
triangle even in the figure and use the sum
of interior angles concept if we join any
one diagonal we get
to triangle but these two triangles also don't tell us anything so
in our construction  Let us
join both the diagonals A and BD.
S C D & D
In This Circle And Each One Divides The Circle
Into Two Segments
Now Understand This Really Well The Colored
Region Is A Major Segment Formed By Cod A And
Angle Ab And Angle Ab Lie In That
Segment Since Angles Formed In The Same Segment Are
Equal  We can say that angle ab
is equal to angle
ab Now look at this blue region it is a major
segment formed by cod b s and it contains two
angles angle b a and angle
bdc so we can say that angle b a is
equal to angle two
BDC Both these pieces are angles formed in
the same
segment Look at the figure Now if we add angle AB
and angle BD S we will get angle A S which is
actually angle d So if we add the
right hand sides of those two equations we
get  Angle d But We Can't Just Add the Right
Hand Sides We Will Have to Add the Left
Hand Sides To Adding These to Equations We
Get Angle Ab P Angle b A Equals Angle d
It Gets Even More
Interesting Since We're Looking for 180
Degrees V  Have to look for some of the angles of
a triangle
look at the left hand side its angle ab ps angle b a this
is angle a b and this
is angle b a if we look at triangle ab the
only angle left out e angle a c
if  When we add an angle to the left hand
side we will get the sum of all the angles of a
triangle a b When we add an
angle to the left hand
side we also have to do it to the right hand
side so we add an angle  A s to both the sides This was one
of the most crucial steps in this
proof You will release that angle A s is the
only angle that is left out and we are
looking for 180 degrees with this step we
get angle ab ps angle b a  p angle a s right
angle d p angle a s this left hand
side edge v saw is the sum of all angles of a
triangle ab which equals 180
degrees the equation we get is 180 degrees
ix angle d plus angle a c veer almost that
angle  A c is actually angle b of the
quadrilateral so we can say that angle d
ps angle b equal to 180 degrees so we
proved one part What about the second part
The proof of the second part is very simple we
know that the sum of all angles  Of a
quadrilateral is
360° angle a p angle b p angle c p angle d
e
360° and out of these four we know that b and
d add up to 180 degrees so we get angle a +
angle c +
180° =
360°  We just replace b + d with 180 degrees
Transposing 180 degrees to the right hand
side We get angle a p angle c equals 180
degrees This was a bit long but remember the
most important part of the proof was to
look for equal angles in a segment and
adding  An Angle to Get the Sum of All Angles
of a Triangle